should you spend your money on official
Mac saave Chargers or get the brand new
ch2 which Apple helped make happen and
is actually cheaper while having the
same 15w charging instead of 7.5 with
every other third-party charger for
iPhones let me tell you that my mind was
blown when I was doing this test because
I looked at everything charging speeds
wattage temperature and I know that you
will not be expecting these results now
I tested these Max safe pucks but these
results also apply for three in-one
Chargers and car chargers because most
of them are only 7.5 unless you spend
way more money or get the new chi2 I
also ordered anor's new 15 wat Mago ch2
battery pack which is the first true 15
wat wireless battery so make sure to
subscribe for that video let's start
with the first test that really
surprised me I used three 15 Pro Maxes
which were completely dead and laid out
the charger starting with a the Maxie on
the left Then ch2 followed by the
original chap Puck I plugged them all in
into an outlet bank with a button to
turn them on to make it perfectly fair
and my first test was to see how long it
would take for the iPhones to turn on
surprisingly official Max safe was the
last one to start charging the iPhone
but when I waited for the phones to turn
on it didn't disappoint it took only
about a minute and a half to turn the
phone on being in first place following
that was the new ch2 charger which took
about 2 minutes and then started the
grueling weight for the 7.5 W charger by
the way all of these were plugged into
identical 30 W Taurus T ice power
adapters to make sure there are no
differences and more than enough power
for the Chargers time was going and I
was getting tired of holding the camera
starting to think that I had a bad 7.5
watt Puck but it was working and the
last 15 Pro Max finally turned on after
a crazy long 10 minutes so we have a
huge difference in the time it takes for
your phone to turn on so you can
actually use it then of course I made
sure the brightness levels were the same
and the phones were set to do not
disturb mode and I turned off the always
on display to make sure we have no
differences at 15 minutes I logged the
charge percentage and maave hit 10% ch2
charged 30% more at 133% while the
original Chi only hit an embarrassing 2%
now if you think it was broken like I
did just wait a little bit both the max
safe and anchors magoi 2 which output 15
wats will pull just over 18 watts to
make this happen but at roughly the 20
minute Mark I couldn't believe that they
are both throttled already with maxi
pulling around 11 Watts but ch2 was
pulling 12 which is why it is charging
faster now you would think that the
original ch1 would be pulling about half
of that but it wasn't it was pulling
over eight so was still maintaining its
full 7.5 watt output instead of
throttling at the 30-minute Mark Maxi
hit 22% but ch2 was able to hit 26 so
it's clearly taking the lead and chi1
was at a measly 12% but that's to be
expected because it's half of the rated
output nowadays 7.5 WT pucks are cheap
and this one only cost 13 bucks compared
to 40 for Max safe but now that ch2 is
out and it's 15 watts you can get one
for only 22 bucks so it is a great deal
compared to Apples Max safe also only
comes with a 3-ft cable which could be
limiting if you want to use your phone
while charging compared to 5 ft with
anchors and the cheap one actually gives
you a 6t cable with this little tie so
that is nice now both apples and anchors
are made out of metal while the cheap
one is plastic and another difference is
how thick these things are the max8 Puck
is very thin compared to the others and
anchor is about twice the thickness so I
thought it would help dissipate heat
better but using my thermal camera you
could see how much more heat was
transferred and trapped to the iPhone
with the anchor it hit 38 celsius
compared to 35 for the others at their
hottest spot and maxafe was actually
having the least heat overall as you
could see in the thermal video at the
45-minute Mark both Max safe and ch2
gained 11% while chi1 G9 which is not
surprisingly bad because it is rated for
half now most people say that slow
charging is better for your iPhone's
battery health because it will have less
heat so some people actually buy these
cheaper 7.5 Watts because of that slower
charging but what shocked me was that
when I tested the heat after 45 minutes
the 7.5 watt cheat was actually the
hottest now at 37° C followed by the
faster 36° ch2 and Max safe being the
coolest at
34° and with much less heat spreading
around so it looks like you're actually
better off doing fast charging at first
and then slowly tapering off when the
phones get hot than having a consistent
7.5 watt load now I did not expect that
at all and there will be a few more
surprises coming out after 1 hour max sa
started to catch up with chi2 being at
43% compared to 45 with original Chi
hitting 28% gaining only 7% in 15
minutes and I think that is because of
heat at 1 hour and 15 minutes we have
53% and 54% for the fast Chargers and
only 33 for the 7.5 watt so at this
point it is already about half an hour
behind in the next 15 minutes
surprisingly all three gain 9% so looks
like the phone's cooled off a bit and
we're all charging at roughly 7.5 Watts
at the 1 hour and 45 minute Mark we have
71% 7 22% and 50 for G1 fun fact if you
using a wired USBC cable you would hit
50% in just 30 minutes at 2 hours max a
finally caught up with ch2 and both hit
79% and 58 for the slow one now 15
minutes later we have 87 87 and 67 so
7.5 watt is consistenly about 20% behind
which at least isn't half the speed like
some might think after 2 and 1/2 hours
max saafe actually took the lead at 94%
compared to 93 and 73 and at 2 hours and
45 chi1 finally hit 80% where charging
speed start to slow down while the
others were almost done at 97 and 96 now
the most insane thing is that in the
next 15 minutes chi1 only gained 1% and
no optimized charging was disabled on
all these phones I think it was just
chilling trying to cool down down the
others were almost charged and then just
after the 3-hour mark they both hit 100%
compared to 81 so for those of you
curious folks ch2 takes the same amount
of time to charge your phone as Max
saave does and in the short term it is
actually quicker which is nice it also
costs only 22 bucks which is a bargain
and the magnet is actually stronger than
Apples and it also comes with that 5T
cable but it definitely Heats your phone
more when and I would expect it to be
cooler being this thick I think that the
inside of it might be more Hollow just
like the cheap G1 Chargers and it
actually uses less metal than Max safe
so I think more of the heat just stays
in your phone with that said I measured
the temps of the pucks themselves right
when the first two hit 100% And maxfe
was a lot cooler overall and it peaked
at 35 watt CSUS compared to 37 for the
other two so if you care about
temperatures you should definitely stick
with genuine Max safe unless you find a
cooler uh that comes with some of these
Chi ones some of them have fans like
esrs now the other benefit of Max safe
is that there are ton of cheap stands
and holders that they will fit into
where the third-party ones won't now the
7.5 wat1 hit 86% at 3 hours and 15
minutes and it basically just crawled in
charging speed finally reach ing 100%
after 4 hours of charging with that it
heated up the phone more so than the
others and it took absolutely forever
for the phone to turn on when we first
started the test so even though it only
cost 13 bucks there is no way that I
would recommend it when anker's new mag
GOI 2 only cost $9 more by the way I
bought all of these myself and no brands
are sponsoring this video so if you want
to pick up one of these I'll just go
ahead and Link them down below now let
me know your thoughts and make sure you
subscribe to see how Apple's Max safe
battery pack which they themselves limit
to 7.5 Watts compares to anor's new 15
wat mag go Che 2 battery pack which cost
less money click right up there to
subscribe and check out one of those
excellent videos right over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video